Film Courage: This is from viewer TJW “When
writing a TV spec, how far in the future should
you know your story, multiple seasons?”
Peter Russell, Screenwriter/Story Doctor:
I would say so.
I think you should know what the ending is
going to be.
What is interesting is you take a show like
MADMEN but you know that at the end of the
show nothing is going to be any different
than the beginning.
It really isn’t.
The first episode of MADMEN Don Draper is
a New York ad man who is really unhappy in
his marriage and he’s got a big hole in
his soul.
What’s the last final scene with Don Draper.
He is going to go back and be a New York ad
man.
He is a seducer of women, he has a problem
with his relationship with women and he’s
got a big hole in his soul, right?
So it’s not hard to know the ending of your
TV show because it’s going to be the same
as your beginning.
There really is no, unless it’s a miniseries
where like TRUE DETECTIVE where season one
Rusty and Marty change incredibly because
that’s a movie basically (remember miniseries
are long movies) you’re always just going
to be in the same place so yeah knowing the
ending is not hard.
You’re going to be in exactly the same place
as you were in the beginning.
BUFFY THE VAMPIRE SLAYER is still slaying
vampires is not happy about it.
[Danny] Glover in ATLANTA for however long
ATLANTA it goes unless he just wants to say
“Screw You!”
I’m not going to do what you expect me to
do, his character is still going to be bumping
along feeling like a loser at the very end
of ATLANTA.
SNEAKY PETE same thing.
SNEAKY PETE is still going to be conflicted
by having a family versus being a con artist,
being along versus being with his family.
I don’t care how many seasons you have.
So it’s not hard figuring out where your
television show is going because it’s going
nowhere.